a nadie le da una respuesta a esta mujer
después de que un paso elevado de la
línea 12 del metro en ciudad de mexico
se desplomara dejando muertos y heridos
otras víctimas mortales del accidente ya
fueron identificadas como es el caso del
esposo de juliana torres quien perdió la
vida tras el derrumbe que nos
comunicaron que el falleció
[Música]
ya nos mostraron fotos a su mamá a su
hermano donde para reconocer el cuerpo
desgraciadamente es él
y al parecer falleció
instantáneamente en el accidente
poco después del accidente del
presidente mexicano dijo que se
investigara sobre las causas del colapso
del metro en ciudad de mexico el pueblo
de mexico tiene que conocer toda la
verdad
no se les va a ocultar nada se tiene que
actuar con responsabilidad como siempre
como lo hemos hecho en el gobierno la
alcaldesa de la capital también anunció
que se llevara a cabo una investigación
con la fiscalía luego de haber pedido
realizar un doble peritaje en el lugar
las operaciones de rescate tuvieron que
ser interrumpidas por el riesgo de que
caigan más partes del tren sobre la vía
una de las más transitadas de ciudad de
mexico el hecho ha planteado muchas
preguntas sobre la seguridad en uno de
los sistemas de metro más concurridos
del mundo y que transporta a millones de
personas diariamente